[music]
go
wiki
I don't know much about the human heart yet but
I want to know
[music]
ah ah ah
you guys are
always pitying me and ridiculing
me  I don't want that
Bad writing It
's the humans who fear me But
[music] It
's
always been humans who
have accepted me
So you don't have to look down
yeah
I want my human name to live mn
[music]
me
ni
[music] I
can't do it
Hahahahaha
The heart of a living
being Stonewah Sometimes it becomes a stronger force than anything else
If you want
to live, even from the brink of death come back to life  It's
especially noticeable on this side, but
you didn't have the slightest bit of that feeling after bleeding to death,
so your wounds won't close
You [music]
resisted now, did
n't you?  No matter how much you don't want
to go,
I want you to stay alive